merci beaucoup pour votre invitation et
effectivement il ya quelques chiffres
qui sont publiés régulièrement dans la
presse et qui montre l'ampleur de la
crise de confiance que les citoyens ont
à l'égard de leur système judiciaire et
plus globalement à l'égard de l'ensemble
de la chaîne pénale
moi je retiendrai deux chiffres
aujourd'hui il ya trois quarts des
citoyens français qui n'ont plus
confiance dans leur justice
il ya environ 45% des français qui
pensent que la démocratie ne permet pas
de bien maintenir l'ordre
donc là je m'adresse aux élus qui sont
ici pour vous dire attention attention
parce que là on est dans une situation
qui est très inquiétante
et cette situation est inquiétante parce
que vous l'avez abordé et auparavant
l'ensemble des tables rondes ont évoqué
ce sujet il y a aujourd'hui un problème
de sécurité dans ce pays
et si je puis me permettre de vous
conseiller je dirais que ce problème de
sécurité aujourd'hui il repose
essentiellement sur un problème
d'inexécution des peines qui sont
prononcées par la justice
c'est le problème fondamental de notre
système aujourd'hui c'est le maillon
faible de la chaîne pénale et si on veut
espérer lutter durablement contre la
criminalité
il faut s'attaquer à ça à ce problème
majeur qui est l'exécution des peines
quelques chiffres très rapidement on a
grosso modo un stock de 100 mille peines
de prison vous l'avez dit monsieur le
député cent mille peines de prison ferme
qui sont en attente d'exécution chaque
année et face à ce stock très important
on a mis en place tout un tas
d'expédients pour éviter d'entrer en
prison on peut permettre de sortir plus
vite
un exemple parmi d'autres aujourd'hui
chaque année il y a quinze mille
personnes qui sont condamnées à de la
prison ferme qui n'y passe pas un seul
jour en vertu du principe de ce qu'on
appelle les aménagements ab initio ses
15000 personnes qui sont condamnées à de
la prison et qui n'y vont pas et il ne
faut pas chercher ailleurs
l'impunité est ressenti par les
délinquants et les criminels ailleurs
que dans ces chiffres
alors vous m'avez demandé d'intervenir
sur la question finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire face à ça parce qu'il
ya des solutions
nous nous préconisons un support à
justice un grand plan important
d'exécution des peines nous avons pu
voir effectivement avec satisfaction que
les républicains proposent aujourd'hui
comme il l'avait fait dans le cadre
en 2012 dans la loi d'exécution des
peines la construction de 20 à 30000
places de prison ferme
c'est indispensable parce que nous avons
une sous dotation carcérale dans notre
pays qui explique l'impunité
l'inexécution des peines et
l'engorgement du système judiciaire
donc il va falloir créer ces places de
prison et supprimer les crédits de
réduction de peine automatiques
les aménagements de peine automatiques
qui ont été créés pour éviter une trop
grande surpopulation mais on peut pas se
contenter à mon avis d'incarcérer
davantage sans penser au temps de la
détention parce que sinon on prend le
risque d'avoir des facteurs de récidive
qui vont s'accroître nous nous
préconisons d'obliger les détenus à
travailler dans les prisons ou à se
former professionnellement
nous préconisons de lutter véritablement
contre les addictions contre la
consommation de drogue contre
l'alcoolisme parce que on sait que ce
sont des facteurs de passage à l'acte
nous préconisons aussi de développer ces
belles les thérapies cognitives et
comportementales alors c'est un peu
technique mais pour vous expliquer très
simplement
l'objectif c'est de lutter notamment
contre l'impulsivité parce que quand on
ne se contrôle pas et qu'on ait remis en
liberté on prend le risque de repasser à
la très rapidement donc il faut par ces
thérapies la permettre une meilleure
réinsertion
et puis malheureusement l'actualité
récente en a beaucoup parlé
nous nous préconisons développer les
unités de vie familiale dans les prisons
pour éviter les permissions de sorties
au cours desquels un certain nombre de
détenus en profite pour s'évader si on
veut éviter qu'ils aient des évasions il
vaut mieux que les détenus restent en
prison
donc voilà pourquoi nous sommes
favorables aux unités de vie familiale
tout ce plan d'exécution des peines
devra reposer également sur une
amélioration de l'évaluation de la
dangerosité criminologique là encore
c'est un terme un peu technique mais on
ne peut pas j'allais dire suivre et
condamné un prédateur sexuel récidiviste
est un voleur de voiture de la même
manière et pour ça il ya des outils très
moderne qui existent qui sont utilisés
dans la quasi totalité des pays
européens qui viennent ces outils du
canada dont on parle très souvent mais
finalement on applique assez peu ce
qu'il ce qu'il propose
l'évaluation de la dangerosité nous
permettra de mieux suivre un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont condamnées
et de sap
liez vous le disiez monsieur le député
sur la rétention de sûreté qui doit être
maintenu le gouvernement a
potentiellement toujours l'objectif de
supprimer ce dispositif de la rétention
de sûreté il faut le maintenir et
peut-être même l'élargir à certains
types de profils je conclurai très
rapidement si vous me le permettez c'est
l'ensemble des peines qui sont
aujourd'hui prononcé qui doivent être
réévaluées je pense aux travaux
d'intérêts généraux je prends ce
bracelet électronique
tous ces dispositifs qui sont utiles et
qu'il faut maintenir doivent être
évaluées et mieux exécuté grâce au
renforcement des bureaux d'exécution des
peines enfin un mot pour conclure il
nous paraît indispensable et nous y
sommes très attachés à l'institut point
justice que les victimes aient toute
leur place dans le système judiciaire et
notamment aussi au moment de
l'application des peines
elles doivent être entendus et tenus
informés si elles le souhaitent des
conditions d'application des peines qui
ont été prononcées contre leur agresseur
par exemple merci beaucoup